today we're gonna be learning about
earthships and I'm so excited to be here
I'm going to be living in an Earthship
which is a sustainable home for 24 hours
and learning what it really means to
live 100 percent off the grid here we
are at picker ease Earthship the place
where you'll be staying tonight let's go
check it up we'll start back here at the
master bedroom this room looks so
comfortable I'm so excited to stay in it
yeah and Mike Reynolds really wanted to
showcase that you can have all of the
creature comforts that you would
normally have just living off-grid and
sustainably all of our appliances and
lights are powered by solar panels when
rain falls it comes and lands on our
roof and then it travels down this path
and goes into this salad bowl and it
collects in the cistern and then that is
used for the house yes exactly
we're gonna cool down your space for you
so we start by opening up this door and
that it has a vent tube that goes all
the way to the back of the building and
is buried in the berm then from there
we're gonna open up your transom windows
which are above the doors those have
already been opened for you and then we
open up the vent boxes oh cool I can
feel the breeze it just smells so good
in here I just smell like all the herbs
and I know the air is so fresh because
there's all these plants here hmm
rosemary
okay I'm cold so I'm gonna try to close
this vent here
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna go meet the guy who
designed to build these structures
humanity has six basic needs that you
can't discount any of them you know it's
comfortable shelter we all need it we
all need water
we all need electricity we all need to
do something with our sewage we all need
to do something with our garbage and we
all need food this vessel that we call
the airship provides these things via
encounter of earth phenomena like Sun
rain wind to provide sustenance for the
person who's in it it's all free it's
all here already if you have sustenance
then money becomes paper which is what
it is I'm gonna pick some of these
Tomatoes for dinner with some rice and
daal that I brought this is my dinner
that I made with the tomatoes I'm
excited to eat I just feel so good in a
space that I know is not exploiting the
environment but trying to work with it
you see all these lights you see all
these lights here they came from the Sun
the power came from the Sun I'm brushing
my teeth with the rainwater
I went pee
and now I'm flushing and it's gonna go
feed the plants I'm taking a hot shower
powered by the Sun wow what a beautiful
way to wake up so I've decided I wanted
our ship and I want to build one what
should I do
we have classes that teach you how to
build your ownership and there are about
4 weeks long and we get students from
all over the world and right here we
have Mike Reynolds teaching students on
the job how to build an airship so what
are all these bottles for so we build
all of our buildings with recycled
materials and these bottles are given to
us from the dump or recycling center and
you also build with tires yep tires are
the main structure for the building and
why is that we have lots of used tires
that are just discarded and they support
the building really well
our relationship of humanity to earth if
we're not contributing to this
relationship if we're only taking from
it
it's just eventually not going to work
anymore and it's starting to not work
for the humans the earth will be fine
the earth will just get so it can't
support humans and humans will be
extinct
our dance with this planet is about over
if we dance in a different way if we
dance with it rather than just taking
from it then we can last a lot longer
[Music]
i beautiful should promise you